head over to the best song ever.com and
purchase our new hit together again it
is a cover of smokey Mike in the god
king that's Jeremy boring and Michael
nolles and with your help we will smash
our way onto the Billboard
charts when we came to this country I my
mom told me how we had so little money
like on on 86 Street in bensen Hurst in
Brooklyn you have a lot of fruit stands
and she'd go to the Fruit stand on on uh
the west side of the all the way west
see how much the grapes were walk all
the way to the other side this down the
block and it's not a short block these
are Avenues in Brooklyn see how much the
grapes were and if it's like a 5cent
difference she would do it and that's
the kind of thing when you're like
really poor you have to make these
considerations so it it like there's few
things that get me like really really
really enraged and the flippancy with
which inflation is talked about as if
like oh it's going to be warmer tomorrow
it's like these are people having make
sacrifice about they have to wake up
half an hour earlier to get to work cuz
they can't afford like some kind surge
pricing or or something for the bridge
or it's it's so gross you know I I I did
a couple of books with DL hugley and one
of the points he made which really kind
of resonate with me and I don't agree
with him specifically but he goes you
know this country hates poor people and
I don't think that's true but it sure
doesn't love them Andes out for them it
doesn't and especially people who are in
power you know the Lefty lefties
traditionally at their best are the
bleeding hearts who are like oh you know
someone's hungry let's get them fed
let's get them clothes you know let's
look out for them and like we you'd
laugh at that but it's like you know
what the older I get the less I laugh at
that and the more I'm like we can use a
little bit more of that and it really
sickens me how much poor people aren't
thought of in this country because they
don't have much power by definition
they're used as Weapons yes exactly the
immigrants are are the poor new poor
people that are being taken care of by
the government it's the people that are
coming across the border being flown
well they they don't come over here with
anything as far as it cost them
thousands of dollars to hire these
coyotes some of these people coming from
North Africa have 10 grand Sometimes
they come in and they owed they have to
pay that back after they get here yeah
sometimes but when we're looking at
North African migrants who paid
Smugglers
$55,000 that's more than a lot of people
in this country could afford to spend on
on on moving now to be fair yes they get
here now they don't have anything
perhaps they shouldn't have spent five
you know between three and five grand or
even upwards of 10 depending on who
they're with to come to this country and
now the fascinating thing is we've got
these videos coming out from like Ashley
stclair Nuance bro had a video and uh
Taylor hon from tenant these people are
giving being given premium economy
they're being flown in the premium seats
on airplanes yeah that's story to their
choice ofation you flew me coach here
you
POS well are you a migrant yeah did you
cross the
border I'm a refugee we will reimburse
you the difference and get you a first
class on the way back I'll tell you I'm
not Joe Biden I'll tell you a funny
story I when I left New York for Austin
oneway ticket I'm like you know what I'm
going to treat myself I'm going to get
first class and the armrests are too far
far apart cuz I'm a
munchkin and I'm like I wasted money for
nothing you can't even use the arm I
can't use all I can think of about
solving the the inflation issue is
making fuel cheaper but it's not just
fuel it's also food it's also rent a lot
of that stuff is result the reason
food's expensive is because you got to
use fuel to get it from the farm factory
but that also doesn't doesn't include
human expectation inflation is also High
because people demand clean running
water air conditioning Refrigeration hot
shower a lot of that stuff comes from
combustion which is carbon based it's
your answer graphine it's your answer
everything H but but it's it's it's an
overly simplistic answer it's not
completely wrong energy plays a huge
role in inflation fuel particularly but
the issue is if people did not want
these things they would work for Less
inflation is a huge component of
inflation is the demands of the people
and what they're willing to work for and
there are a lot of Millennials there's a
poll that came out Millennials are
broken people the Millennials said they
would only be they would be happy with
500,000 a year every other generation
they said a sacrifice yeah every other
generation said 120 yeah of course 120
and I'm happy millen's like 500 now what
what do you think happens you take a
generation of people who want 500 Grand
and you say hey we want to pay you we'll
pay $15 an hour to work at Starbucks
they go no I want 500 Grand you're like
okay well we need to hire people and
they're demanding massive salaries
because they want to be able to buy a
bunch of stuff the average person
doesn't want they make this argument
poverty shouldn't exist abolish poverty
these other arguments like poverty today
is wealth 400 years ago there will
always be pover 100 years ago seriously
because poverty is relative yes so it's
not so simple inflation is not just a
component of the cost of fuel it's
demands of the population and what
they're willing to work for inflation
and the cost of goods is a component of
how much energy a person will spend for
one hour in exchange for how much energy
do they get back and everybody wants
more energy back than they put out
Millennials want five to 10 times the
energy they put out back and so it's not
so simple to just say cheaper energy
solves the problem because when you
let's say we do have an energy
Revolution energy becomes 10% cheaper
you know what happens who's the who's
the guy who did that formulation for the
cost of gas based on the the uh the use
of gas based on the cost of gas he
basically early 1900s found that when
gas is cheaper people spend the same
amount of money on gas they just drive
more when you make gas expensive they
just drive less and the price and and
and they spend a flat cost yes that if
someone has 50 bucks left over they'll
be like I'll just for no reason I
wouldn't consider 10% a revolution if if
you could drop the cost of fuel by like
99% that would be a revolution and what
we end up seeing is people will just
drive more maybe or they'll be get so
much time or or they'll just use more
gas cons consuming Vehicles like the
rocket sh this is ex no but this is
exactly what they saw when gas got
cheaper people bought gas guzzlers
because gas is cheap now right it did
not it does not s you you you look at
this issue and you're like a single
individual can make the decision that
because gas is cheaper I'll live
frugally and I'll save10 bucks and buy
more food not what happens on the macro
level people will drive more they'll buy
gas guzzlers and the amount they spend
on travel Remains the Same people us
used to not be able to afford meat in
this country right used to be a big
thing now everyone even though the price
have gone up have can can afford meat
it's not they eating less meat they just
buy more yeah
yeah yeah the cost of food gets cheaper
people don't don't save money on food
now they just eat until they're dead I
think that's why the not depopulation
but degrowth uh this that they people
want the human race to be expanding
slower it's like you know might call it
conspiracy I don't know
butc I think that's why it is explicit
because humans unfettered will just
expand and grow and consume said well
any animal but that's not the problem it
is absolutely amazing looking at the
International Space Station I believe
the cost of it was $3 billion and all of
the Power of human Minds all across the
planet came together to develop
technology and the capability to send
people into space to live up there for
months on end that is human Minds coming
together more people means we'll just
start colonizing off the planet we'll
figure these things out the problem is
culture and so degrowth is not the
answer they're saying you know live in
the pot eat the bugs well that's that's
an argument the solution actually is
cultural change people need to be they
need they need to eat less food they
need to recognize food is cheap now
don't buy 10 times of it they need to
recognize Community is important you
need to have uh creativity culture and
the problem is while we have a ton of
amazing people working hard to develop
technology so we can go outer space we
have too many people who uh what is a uh
youal Harari call them useless eaters
and so the solution in my view to the
quote unquote useless eater is wow look
at all these people that could put their
potential to the advancement of human
civilization that haven't been properly
appropriated and what have they say put
them in pods give them the bugs and let
them play video games until they no
longer exist and don't have kids Harvest
their body heat for electricity that's
not a real thing though that's you can
Harvest piso electricity like heat
friction from electricity the energy
loss from that it's a matri The Matrix
did that and the only reason they came
with that concept was because people
wouldn't understand the concept of a
neural net so you know harnessing energy
from a human body is ridiculous did The
Matrix just do that because they had to
have a reason why they didn't just kill
all the people no it was uh uh the
original idea in The Matrix was that
first humans chose the Matrix oh that
makes more sense okay and that is Canon
and that the the reason the robots
needed them was for a neural network to
basically create a massive okay that
makes sense to their brains are used to
compute The Matrix the argument that
more people means more expansion isn't
it's not doesn't track because like a
deer population if it expands too
rapidly it'll eat all the food and then
it'll starve and'll have a mass
starvation of deer deer don't invent
invent spaceships though yes but most
humans don't either it's a very very
small percentage of humans that have
that kind of mind capacity that's not
true at all well because the Cobalt we
use for our technology is not mined by
rocket scientists slaves yeah but
Rockets so we don't like the conditions
in the Cobalt mines but we're not going
to send Einstein to a Cobalt mine you
you the the what what we should have is
a forested gump likee person who can't
build a rocket but dude can run really
really fast you can run fast sure
undoubtedly yes there there is a role
for everyone on God's green earth the
problem is oh no no no you're I
completely disagree you don't think so
no most people are as irrelevant as a
butterfly and they have as much impact
on on and they can't they can't break
rocks for us sure but I I but we are at
a point where chat GPT is a better
conversationalist than the average human
being but I don't care about
conversation I care about who's going to
pick up the Cobalt for our smartphones I
think much of these things like Co like
like can be done by robots or machines I
that's I do not believe that's correct
right now perhaps in the future sure I
don't think it's I don't think it's
going be far in the future it's just not
it's just not it's not um economically
Fe Fair Point perhaps the big concern of
the Bill Gates types is that once we
come to a point where uh trivial and
menial labor is done by machines you
will only require higher thinking human
beings in which case the quote unquote
useless leader useless eaters become a
very serious liability we're at a point
where I would much rather and most other
people would rather interact with the
touchscreen than with cashier at a fast
food place because the odds of me
getting my order correct are much higher
and it's going to be more faster and
more efficient that's a problem I I I
agree and disagree uh I think you you
are correct it will likely be higher but
I also think the issue is not just the
cashier but the guy making the food
correct so until we eliminate that role
but that's also happened now they have
the maches they have they have fully
automated McDonald I think it's
McDonald's I could be wrong but there
was a video I saw where you go to a Kias
in order and then behind the counter you
actually watch the robot arm grab the
burger yeah put it on the grill take it
out flips puts it on the bun then the
thing drops all the ingredients folds
itated Taco Bell in somewhere in the
midwest it's like a drive-thru
completely there are no humans who work
there find so I think I'm pretty sure it
may have been you've all know Harari who
said this or someone else but the idea
that they have is when the next
Industrial Revolution happens to avoid a
lite Riot what you have to do is before
the Revolution plate the masses by
stimulating dopamine put them in a
situation where they can play video
games all day and get free food they
will
eventually just die off and then you we
won't have to worry about violence so
what's interesting is you have that book
right there which I just interviewed
Alex Jones about the great reset and his
entire book is about quotes from these
guys where they're not just it's not
like horror porn they're advocating for
Brave New World like this is what we
want there's no other way around it um
and I don't think that I think this is
actually a real concern because what if
you are a millennial low IQ low ambition
uh a sense of entitlement what am I GNA
what what am I I'm going to be making
I'm going to be breaking Cobalt in the
minds no I'm not so so what do you do
with that where's the problem what do
you do with that person you give him a
video game sure that's right exactly
that's the point and so where's the
problem then are any of us upset that
entitled woke Millennials will go lock
themselves in a pod eating bugs and
playing the Matrix at a certain point if
they're all on welfare it's going to
become costly and someone's going to be
like why are we paying for all these
people in their pods video games that's
when the problem comes in so they don't
run around burning everything down
because they don't want to break rocks
sure but the point is then they start
reproducing and they start voting all
sorts of other things start happening
which is why they're also sterilizing
themselves and aborting their children
sure but I don't think they're Al
they're sterilizing themselves means
thinking ahead so a lot of them are not
going to be thinking ahead because
they'll be operating on a Pleasure
Principle have you seen the there's
there's a article that was being shared
it said study finds uh single uh women
are H in their 40 or what like Sing Sing
women are happier when they're single
and
childless that's that I think that's
what it was and it showed like a clip
from the show Girls and then my response
was yeah until they're 35 right yeah MH
but for real and so what's happening is
you have this corporate press apparatus
telling all these young women not to
have families and they buy into it but
the thing is this isn't even some
hypothetical sci-fi thing this is
literally like 20 2019 right it's
already been happening for years Al Alex
Jones described it as they tell you they
are setting bear traps and if you are
too stupid to avoid them it's your own
fault I don't think it's too stupid it's
too trusting and we're taught since
we're kids to trust these people so it's
very hard to be like holy crap I've been
lied to since kindergarten thanks for
watching this clip from the timcast IRL
podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8:00 p.m. and become a
member over at timcast.net